well as we search for content how about
Stefon Diggs newly acquired by the
Buffalo Bills he had a suggestion on
Twitter yesterday top five wideouts to
ever play the game go so we will go and
we're gonna go maybe five rounds here
depending upon how long we talk to
support each of our picks we are going
to draft Chris the all-time greatest
receivers to ever play the game a
professional football and we are
conceding that Jerry Rice is the number
one greatest of all time sorry Randy
Moss he tried to make the argument 2012
that a Tim it's not it's Jerry Rice he's
the goat he gets there we'll call it
like we did a few weeks ago the Joe
Montana memorial draft even though he's
not dead this is the Jerry Rice memorial
draft even though he's not dead so we
will continue from there and there's no
trivia question today
so Chris I'll just let you uh how we
gonna determine the first pick cuz I
want the first pick are you gonna give
me the worst pick go ahead I'll let you
have the first pick on a day like today
go ahead that's fine who do you who do
you think I'm gonna pick um I don't know
who you're gonna pick I don't think
you're gonna pick Randy Moss I don't so
I don't know where you're gonna go I'm
actually very I'm very intrigued who is
it gonna be I'm picking Terrell Owens
I'm picking Terrell Owens and and the
difference between Terrell Owens and
Randy Moss is this even though Terrell
Owens at times was a colossal pain in
the butt plenty of receivers are
colossal pains in the butt folks from
time to time I've heard stories about
how you used to get Jerry Rice out of
the locker room when they knew that the
fuse was about to hit the bomb and he
was gonna blow so they they got him
dressed and gone and in his car before
the media ever showed up but that you
know the thing that still bothers me
about Randy Moss I play when I want to
play the the you know quitting on the
Raiders the the consistent fare to get
the absolute most out of his god-given
ability that bothers me to this day so
that's why I take Terrell Owens because
all the things you can say about Terrell
Owens you can never say he did not bust
his ass every single day to be the best
receiver he could be and you can never
say that he quit on his team he may have
been disruptive but he never quit on his
team the year that he was trying to get
traded by the Eagles he still had over
100 receiving yards per game
in the games that he played yeah but
sometimes is this you know distractions
and side antics led to him not being may
be as good as he could be and caused
issues with the team too so you know I
could very easily argue that as well to
go okay yeah he was the best receiver on
that team but that team is dysfunctional
because of him so you know that's just
one thing I will push on that but I'm
still going with Randy Moss as my first
pick and I hear you you know the things
you said are real I get it Randy Moss is
you know one of those guys we would put
on the list as Devo wide receivers he's
one of the greatest athletes we've ever
seen the sport and not to say Terrell
Owens is not I get that but I can just
remember a few things first off seeing
Randy Moss in person is a special event
it really is because he's like a praying
mantis yet he's the fastest guy in the
field he's got this some of the greatest
hands we've seen in the history of the
sport you had to change your game plan
when you played Randy Moss and when I
first got to Tampa Bay
you know the Bucs were one of the best
defenses of football coming off the
Superbowl and I remember you know John
Lynch and Ronde Barber talking about you
know the old NFC central battles then
they were gosh good thing we don't have
to deal with Randy Moss anymore I don't
have to worry about getting 40 yards
deep when I'm playing cover two because
you know he could get up on my toes and
four steps so this is one of the
greatest weapons physical physically
gifted specimens we've ever seen in the
sport that's why I'll make him my number
one guy and I agree with you completely
and that's the basis for my beef any cat
that's what made him him Lawrence Taylor
but he had been the same if Stevie was
sitting at home lifting weights and
drinking a protein shake I don't know
that might have took the edge away from
him on the field so part of being you
know that guy Randy Moss is is just part
of him and also what made him great on
the field there's another guy who has
more than a thousand career receiving
yards than either Terrell Owens or Randy
Moss and he's still playing my next pick
Larry Fitzgerald who still has a chance
to catch Jerry Rice although I don't
think it's going to happen but Larry
Fitzgerald is the guy who just keeps
plugging away goes about
business never creates any issues never
creates any problems has stayed with the
Cardinals his entire crew at a time
where that wanderlust eventually kicks
in for a guy and he ends up with a
different team he fights to stay with
the Cardinals he takes below market
deals to stay with the Cardinals and he
continues to be one of the most
important players for that franchise
surely he was a tremendous influence
last year on helping Kyler Murray become
as good as he was as a rookie and
Fitzgerald back for another year
we'll see how high he can push his
numbers but the most significant player
in the history of the Cardinals
organization and they've been around for
a long time and I'm looking at putting
Nick Bose on his butt sit down Nick not
Larry Fitzgerald for me and Andy you
know you could make the case and you may
be able to make the case when he's done
that that he was better than massarone's
well you know maybe more consistent for
sure not as explosive with the ball in
his hand or when the ball was in the air
but maybe more versatile as a complete
wide receiver would be the thing that
jumps out to me about Fitzgerald and
maybe can use them in different ways
slot outside whatever it may be but has
more of that you know ultimate
professional approach that we saw from
like a Jerry Rice that way and I'm with
you I think Larry Fitzgerald probably
would have been my next pick too so you
stole that I'm gonna say with somebody
else here who I don't think gets
involved in this conversation enough and
I think that's Marvin Harrison that's
the guy I'm gonna throw on this list I
mean first off who he didn't even Marvin
they never heard of him well you know he
was on the NFL all 100 thing about Mary
Harrison I don't anything you don't know
well you know you it's just I guess
right now your head let me just tell you
he's part of one of the greatest
quarterback wide receiver duo's we've
ever seen in the history of the sport I
mean we talk about young and rice and
Montana and Rice well right after that
is Manning to Harrison and you know
Marvin Harrison is a guy and you know
listen all you gotta do is watch the NFL
top 100 and watch Bill Belichick talk
about him about how he always had a
double-team him and he was very hard to
figure out you know how they were gonna
use him Harrison was a guy that yeah you
could put in the slot and he could run
some of those really refined routes but
he also could put him outside and he can
run a 80 yard post over you
had to just fly by you so had great
versatility you know as far as a
receiver is concerned better than like
Randy Moss at teo as far as versatility
is concerned you know he didn't have a
big personality wasn't a diva wide
receiver he might have some other issues
we know that okay but nonetheless he was
one of the best receivers I've seen in
my lifetime yeah well you know what I'm
talking about next for me Chris Carter
and look not not a spectacular game
breaking down the field guy but he
caught everything thrown in his
direction he's sixth all-time in
receptions there's a couple of tight
ends in front of him so he's fourth
all-time among receivers in catches and
he is fourth all-time in receiving
touchdowns with 130 all he does is catch
touchdowns yes that's all he does and he
did it almost as well as anyone other
than well he did it better than anyone
other than Jerry Rice Randy Moss and
Terrell Owens so give me Chris card I
mean he was the guy that on third down
you knew he was gonna be open you knew
he was gonna make the catch you knew he
was going to extend the drive and every
once in a while every once in a while he
turned the corner he'd take off running
and he'd surprise you with his ability
to get to the end zone from maybe 40
yards out but for the most part he was
just that bad he was that basketball
player on a football field who was
always able to go grab the ball wherever
it was yeah I mean he was up Chris's
microphone just died
there is Chris back you hear me Danny
back Chris go ahead Chris okay sorry yep
I think my earpods died out but either
way yeah I'm with you there I mean Chris
Carter you know caught the ball in
traffic he could beat you deep you know
it was great back shoulder type thrower
you know and again other guy who was
pretty versatile especially at the end
of his career he worked the middle of
the field a whole lot more than he did
the outside of the field and that's
where he was special so I'm with you
there all right huh this is a tough
decision here I am going to go with
Julio Jones as my next pick
well gentleman's yeah for my money is
one of the greatest receivers I've ever
seen I mean what more can you say about
Julio Jones I'm
he's got everything to me sighs you know
yak when the balls in his hand he could
take a 6 yard slant and go 80 yards for
a touchdown he can beat you deep with
just pure speed he could jump up over
you like a moss like a Randy Moss and
catch the ball that way so you know in
my lifetime especially and I know we're
probably doing you know not doing some
of the great receivers of yesteryear
great service here because we're being a
little too into modern modern sports
here but Julio Jones is one of the
physically freakiest people wide
receivers we've ever seen in the league
and he's been you know the best receiver
in football are in that conversation
four top two or three really for like
the last eight years and that's a pretty
damn good run along with being
professional along with it so yeah Julio
Jones makes my list yeah look I
understand that and he still got a long
way to go left in his career relatively
speaking and his numbers may pump up as
time goes by and I agree with you we are
showing a little bit of a bias toward
guys who played more recently but you
know what these are the guys we've seen
and the guys we've studied and all due
respect to the guys of yesteryear the
game has changed and maybe some of these
guys would have had much bigger
statistics and been much more memorable
if they had played at the time when the
rules were relaxed in favor of the
passing game but they didn't and also
the game has exploded from the
standpoint of how much we see it how
much access we have to it and fantasy
football and whatnot and I think that
has contributed to this bias and again
I'm building up to my pick which is
another guy who played more recently
than not and that's Tim Brown your old
teammate in Tampa Bay how could you not
have picked him Brown Tim Brown
hall-of-famer took him a little while to
get in but he got in he had nearly 1,100
receptions he was a guy who was always
consistent he was a guy who always you
know it was it was he's almost like the
Larry Fitzgerald of his day just kind of
take him for granted right he gets it
done he generates big numbers and
because he's not flashy because he's not
loud because he's not look at me look at
me because he's not involved in contract
disputes I mean the most outlandish
thing he ever said came well after he
retired when he suggested Bill Callahan
through Super Bowl 37 has a favor to Jon
Gruden which
something to talk about for a few days
and I appreciated that but Tim Brown
just a rock-solid great player and
ultimately got what he deserved a spot
in the Hall of Fame yeah III I'm just
gonna pick him last round I was really
kind of torn between him and Julio Jones
and I I didn't go Tim Brown cuz I just
didn't think you would do it I didn't
think you would go there quite yet so
yeah that I got burned by that but but I
got the ultimate respect for Tim Brown
and he's another guy I mean just can do
everything and was an ultimate
professional doing it and not to forget
like you know I I can still remember
like coaches telling you what would a
Tim Brown been if he didn't tear his ACL
his rookie or second year because you
know if anybody remembers this guy won
the frickin Heisman Trophy you don't see
wide receivers win the Heisman Trophy
you know that's how explosive he was and
he was one of the best kick returners
and punt returners but ended up being
one of the greatest receivers we ever
saw and truly one of the greatest
teammates I ever played with Mike I mean
he was awesome and you talk about a guy
who used to put perspective into me when
like John Gurdon used to cuss me out all
the time you know he didn't like it Tim
Brown he'd always like man I've never
seen a coach talk to a player like that
he'd give me pep talks to be like hang
in there don't listen to him or whatever
it may be he still talks about it so I
love Tim Brown he's one of my favorite
teammates I ever had no doubt about that
um how what round are we in I don't even
know what frickin round we're in right
now I think this is Round four okay well
I'm gonna go I'm goin I'm goin crazy
again here maybe did what some people
think Andre Johnson is going to make my
greatest receivers of all time list
alright yeah I mean Andre Johnson is
again one of the freak shows of modern
history at the wide receiver position
now he gets lost under the radar why
because of his team the Houston Texans
never really in any big playoff games we
never took them seriously as a Super
Bowl contender he played with a middle
of the league type quarterback his whole
career and still put up gigantic numbers
and was by far the number one our all
weapon on that Houston Texans team his
whole career but it didn't matter I mean
I know when I played on the Tennessee
Titans man we used to play the Houston
Texans and we would double cover him and
he'd still run 70 yard posts right by us
so for me Andre Johnson is one of the
greatest receivers to ever play the game
statistically he's up there to where
where is he at I just want to make sure
he's eleventh all-time in receiving
yards and I think without a legit number
two or a big-time quarterback around him
I think he has that's what they've even
been better
so yeah I'm Jerry Johnson making the
list for me round five Chris Sims and
I'm going with a guy who and where this
is old school real old school well
before either of us were born Don Hudson
played from 1935 to 1945 for the Packers
he had 17 touchdown receptions in 1942
in 11 games he finished with 99
touchdown receptions for his career that
record stood for 44 years until Steve
Largent broke it he had 99 in that era
they were playing 10 games a year 11
games a year Don Hudson was well ahead
of his time I don't know how he would
have fared nobody knows how he would
have fared in the modern game but he was
as dominant and the most dominant
receiver of his era
the most dominant receiver really before
the NFL realized that the games a lot
more exciting if the balls in the air
more frequently yeah it's insane I mean
it really is and then you know like I
said I'm really sorry to some of these
old receivers and we are we have
disrespected them too you know Fred
Biletnikoff of the world you know John
Stallworth Lynne swans drew Pearson's I
mean yes modern-day times the NFL
passing all that has led to what do you
want to say what what are you making
faces about no time greats don't mention
Drew Pearson died because you know every
time you mentioned Drew Pearson well
fortunately Kristen short staff so she
can't hit the b-roll of the Hail Mary
play but drew Pearson's not even in the
Hall of Fame he's not gonna make this
list well we're still we're missing a
lot of all-time great receivers is what
I'm saying that's all you know there's
there's some older guys that we're
leaving out and I feel bad about it I do
you know III yeah there are increasing
could still pull it off
Kristen way to go man looks like a Hall
of Fame type play to me that's
interference offensive alright who's
your pick second angle - alright I I
want to pick Steve Largent alright but
I'm not gonna do that
I'm going to pick Antonio Brown I think
Antonio Brown yeah I don't care
wow I don't think we saw anybody do what
Antonio Brown did and basically a
seven-year career alright because he
wasn't the focal point of their offense
in year one or even year - if I remember
and of course didn't even play last year
and you know in that short of time the
numbers he put up now listen he has a he
had a good quarterback and a good
offense around him and all those things
but I don't do brown you know I think if
you ask Bill Belichick Oh what we gonna
do when you played Pittsburgh we're
gonna double-team Antonio Brown every
time we're gonna make somebody else beat
us he was that type of guy you knew they
were gonna go with the ball with him and
yeah underneath deep balls
it didn't matter he could do it all and
even for his size he's a great 50/50
ball catcher - which is amazing so you
know I'm not in love with the person
Antonio Brown he does bother me at times
with some of his antics but I still
think he's one of the greatest receivers
I've seen in my lifetime I do feel that
way alright that's our five round draft
we haven't done a five round draft in a
long time if ever
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports